audience my name is do buskers moondust
miss mine stop oh my god I can't believe
I finally made it YouTube high school
I'm so excited to make videos I think
this will make a great 200 part series I
love making videos I love it so much
well then I better hurry to get started
ahh oh my god I'm so sorry for bumping
into you guys I totally didn't see you
how dare you you've been touched by an
impure don't you know who we are guys go
easy on him
I think he's new shut up shut your mouth
paddy power no one touches me
oh [ __ ] that's right Tyler now apologize
guys please just do this for me all
right fine
I'm sorry I'm so sorry that's okay since
you're new I will let you go for now the
but you should know the way to grow
subscribers is to pretend that you're
friends with everyone so give me a
compliment ah okay you have a you have a
you have a face yeah